you think mark dead but he ain't you
think I'm Rick but I'm really mark you
think is gonna heyguys markiplier here
in case you didn't know I was gone yeah
I was gone to South Carolina and it has
been an ass it's been an absolutely
horrible time trying to get back on I'll
explain later but right now I'm just
happy to be home more than anything I
have all my my little plushie dolls here
and I I'm just like oh uh anyway no like
okay here here's the thing I went down
to UM I went out into South Carolina
because I was filming with cyndago I
love to do that I do that occasionally I
don't always say what I'm gonna do go
down there because while we were working
on this really cool project wait wait no
come on okay we were working on this
really cool project that's kind of like
hush-hush ting but if you were following
me on Facebook and Twitter and I highly
recommend that you do to keep up with my
daily life like the whole hair
extravaganza that went down um it was
we're working on this really cool
project that a lot of you guys to know
about anyway um though Oh
getting back um there was this huge
storm that ran through like the Midwest
and eastern coast yesterday and it
caused all sorts of flights to get
delayed my flight got canceled delayed
reinstated canceled again
I got switched to another flight that
was still delayed and then I couldn't
make my connection flight so I was like
stuck in Charlotte and what happened was
I was calling up hotels and there was
like busy busy busy and I called the
Sheraton in Charlotte and they were like
the guy on the phone was like oh I can't
make a reservation but you can walk in
to get the walking rate so I'm like oh I
can walk in and they have a room for me
there and he goes yeah they have a room
for either so I got on the cab I cabbed
all the way to the hotel
you know I get there they don't have no
rooms and so I'm like I it's alright
I just need to get to another hotel so I
can go to sleep and then I can wake up
for my flight in the morning so they
called me a cab this is like at 12:15
a.m. like after midnight in and they
call a cab and the cab doesn't show up
for like an hour it doesn't show up at
all
it it's an hour later the cab doesn't
show up I've asked them repeatedly like
where's cab I'm kind of tired I want to
go find someplace to sleep and so they
said oh no we called the cab we call him
back like three times and they keep
saying that the cabs on its way but the
capital was in honest way so I'm like
getting more and more frustrated just
because I'm sitting in the lobby of a
hotel that I can't sleep in does I want
to get to another hotel and this
wouldn't happened if Sheridan didn't
either they had a room that's all the
studs point I don't want to go on a big
rant about that store stuff but they
called the second cab and I was another
hour later I was sitting in the lobby of
that hotel for two hours waiting for
cabs that never showed up never showed
up so I was just like so unbelievably
Agoura all I wanted to do was go to bed
I just wanted to go bed in anyway so
finally after two hours dirt and decided
that they would drive me with a shuttle
to another hotel and then I finally got
to bed and then I finally woke up got in
my plane got in literally not 15 minutes
ago oh there we go
were you doing okay my can't are I sorry
my camera was freaking out I don't know
okay so I got in like 15 minutes ago I
ordered myself a pizza and I don't even
really drink much soda but I got me a
self a two liter I'm gonna sit down and
relax and then I'm gonna get right back
to cracking with videos for you guys
because
sincerely although I have rough days
like this and you know it happens them
whatever but I mean I wouldn't trade my
job for a in the world
I have I sincerely love you guys all the
support that you've given me like it
makes it all worth it I wouldn't mind
going through like this every day if it
still meant that I could make videos and
interact with you guys can be here for
you guys because like I don't I've never
had a job that I love as much as this
one and I've never I don't even consider
a job it's more of just like a hobby
that I get to do for a living and and
just honestly sincerely like I would be
nowhere without you and your support
just means absolutely the world to me
and I just want you guys to know that
every single time I'm so unbelievably
grateful for everything that you've done
for me and given me these opportunities
to be stuck in different places so just
sincerely thank you guys so much for
everything that everything that you guys
have done I don't have much else for
substance in this vlog besides my little
rant about what happened in explanation
but um there's more cool stuff on the
way I'm actually leaving again on
Wednesday to go to LA to work with some
people ah yeah huh not to do with the
deadliest warriors thing actually
something completely different I hope
you like that deadliest worries but I
had a lot of fun making that it's it way
longer than its Jennifer announcement
video but that's the kind of stuff that
I really like to do I love to make
really creative stupid things for the
most random of reasons so uh I mean
that's just another reason why I'm so
grateful I get to be creative and be
myself around you guys so just thank you
guys so much for everything I'm gonna go
eat I'm gonna go relax and then I'm
gonna go write recording I'm gonna see
if Wade's available for more seven days
to die I got other games that I want to
play for you guys more to come just
sincerely thank you and my hair is a
mess I know apparently my hair can cause
mass hysteria in in the entire world
it's getting a little long I don't know
should I cut it or should I
oh no hmm enough so anyway thank you
guys so much for watching hope you enjoy
everything's going on you think you love
Margot blur but he loved you yeah bye